palestinian activist hen sreyde and her
husband obey
are unsure how to tell their children
about their arrest
by the palestinian police early in july
obey was detained
ahead of a protest against the
palestinian authority the police said
the gathering didn't have a permit
when hint protested his detention she
herself was assaulted
and detained my five-year-old boy had
always wanted to be a policeman
on his sixth birthday he asked me for a
costume after he saw the police assault
me and release me at 3am
he told me the police are scary don't
get me that costume
hint took part in a wave of protests
against the palestinian authority
that were broken up using excessive
force
some journalists were banned from
reporting others
detained and beaten and a few said they
were sexually harassed
it's unusual for reporters to be wearing
flak jackets while
covering protests in ramallah city
center
the security forces and fatigue
loyalists have assaulted journalists
while they were reporting on
demonstrations against the palestinian
authority in recent weeks
the death of a prominent activist while
in pa's custody
has sparked wide calls for reforms
a top aide of the palestinian president
apologized to the family of the activist
a good start says activist omar asaf but
he wants
justice he believes the palestinian
authority is
intimidating critics in a way he hasn't
seen before
unfortunately the palestinian authority
performs a security role in its security
coordination with the israeli occupation
al jazeera spoke to feter officials who
warned the current movement
could be used to destabilize the
political system
pushed by foreign agendas they added
that some journalists
are taking part in protests recent polls
show that the dissatisfaction with the
palestinian authority
is at its highest levels since it was
established
despite the growing anger the protests
aren't expected to expand
hamas is refraining from using its base
in the west bank
in any organized manner
to participate the reason for this i
think
that's my own reading of why hamas
is staying away from the demonstrations
and the expression of anger with the
president and the pa
the fear of civil war many political
analysts say a street fight is imminent
if there's a vacuum in the political
system and scenes like these
could spiral out of control if plans for
president mahmoud abbas's succession
remain vague ibrahim al-jazeera
the occupied west bank